واجهه مباشره بين حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه
سياسيا ودينيا مع تيار اليسار في مدينه تل
ابيب التي تعد العصب الرئيسي للحياه
الاقتصاديه لاسرائيل
انا اعتقد ان الحكومه الحاليه ستؤثر
وتهاجم الديمقراطيه تريد اضعاف المحكمه
العليا وتضر بالعلمانيه
للدوله ستمنع ايضا المواصلات ايام السبت
هذا يقلقني
الاسرائيليون يتخوفون من قرارات حكومه
نتنياهو التي تحاول فرض واقع جديد من خلال
اضعاف المحكمه العليا وفرض ايديولوجيا
اليمين المتشدد ما يؤثر على الحياه
اليوميه لدى سكانها ومن قرارات منع
المواصلات العامه في ايام السبت في تل
ابيب كخطوه غير مسبوقه
في اي دوله نريد اولادنا ان يكبروا
الاتجاه مقلق نشعر انه يخرج عن التوازن
الكثير من العمر
قريبا عشرات الالاف من تيارات مختلفه في
اسرائيل يواصلون الاحتجاج ويستعدون للخروج
غدا في تل ابيب للتعبير عن قلقهم من اكثر
حكومه يمنيه متشدده في تاريخ اسرائيل
وصفين
بالعدائيه
وعصيان مدني محتمل هذا ما يمكن ان تتسبب
به المواجهه الداخليه مع حكومه نتنياهو
اذا استمرت في سياستها التصعيديه التي
توصف هنا بالديكتاتوريه
من تل ابيب العربيه